hello and welcome to this video playing
on a 101 okay III oftentimes no not this
time
that signals if you go if they go III
and D for that signals the intention to
play him the soul war reverse Stonewall
yeah now we have transposed into a
benoni the style of opening White has
played the not so aggressive move III
but it's so totally okay
that's a bit uncommon normally 94 is
prevented in such a situation with 92
because the piece trades are generally
believed to be beneficial for black not
like like a spatula but like posing
problems I'm definitely happy to trade a
bit in such a modern benoni position
often times my general rule is that if
Black gets to trade down to 2 minor
pieces is usually ok your opponent
offers a draw no we don't know what it
is with the draw office who offers the
draw in a blitz game okay so Queen a5
maybe let me think about it for a moment
if I go Queen a5 Bishop d2 Queen a to us
that justice at risk here could be a bit
risky but I mean I don't think it traps
the Queen or anything
Queen a5 is mostly to prepare b5 now I
think this is a modern Benoni position
that's definitely fine for black
sometimes with the lack of space you
don't really know what to do with four
minor pieces but if you are down to two
this is often the idea count yeah you
have the good Bishop long diagonal and
the knight can be used on the Queen side
if you have even more pieces 3/4 yeah
you don't sometimes know what to do with
them in particular the c8 bishop is some
often times completely useless
yeah not quite a king I was thinking we
need to look a one queen bee - are not
going to get I'm not going to get the
Queen trapped
don't like it's ok sigh take it and to
be won at the end I have to go to f6
look b7 the thing is this is a pretty
decent alternative though I'm going for
it
now b3 I can simply take a look I want
to anything the bishop is covering it
and queen a4 is preparing to play a c4
he wants to trade even more I mean again
I don't mind that that much even a
purely heavy piece configuration is fine
sometimes is even better than having
like one or two minor pieces so let's
see what he is up to or she for that
matter
could be yeah
so white is probably taking know that's
an interesting move after the capture
okay I ever take anyway so let's do it B
6 and this is now a double threat I'm
threatening to take here and play rookie
4 or queen evil okay so whoopee four or
Queenie for the Queen cannot be attacked
so rookie 4 is better right
simply stopping wait
let's flick this end
you can stop see for here you should do
it
okay yes okay
yeah that was not at all an interesting
defense and I don't think it should be
sufficient ultimately but wide White's
position was very shaky and this could
be a way to limit the damage okay Quincy
for I have fry I don't want to trade
Queens here even though the Queen's rate
is certainly giving me an advantage
Queen d2 looks more dangerous I'm
attacking so III and most mostly I'm
threatening Group B - yeah here d5 I can
take so it's two points anyway - this
one
covering the pawn and tried to push the
deep horn oh that I take you Paul okay I
cannot resist yeah and it's going to be
a queen yeah
okay so let's have a look there was some
interesting moments here this is
actually a theoretically explored
position that has been played by many
good players on the white side as an
entire guru failed but I think white
mostly tries to prevent 94 now I guess
with 92 and then later with a 4 and so
on we get a fairly regular Benoni
white being probably a temple down in
some kids like III 4 is a tempo down on
a normal benoni but the tempo is even
though that may not be known he is quite
dynamic it's not so relevant it seems
but he went through he won or she went
through k1 and 94 I think is useful the
engine does not agree interestingly
enough but I think it is still useful to
trade this now I got a little bit more
space for my pieces and here it's
difficult to prevent the activation of
the bishop Age 3 is some move that is
aimed to prevent Bishop g4 but not
Bishop f5 the engine wants to play E for
interesting name should G form Bishop b5
and b6 yeah and this this is a thing is
okay I can take on a3 and even though
it's got the bishop here I've got I've
got some good possibilities yes it's a
very decent benoni with two pieces
traded this was also already very
comfortable b1
Queen a5 Bishop d2 I think taking is
probably okay but I was there was a bit
scared him I didn't see 95 anyway I was
I was totally overlooking that I'm
attacking a woman it was a really bad
way of playing
I was thinking b7 is hanging which is
true what this is a small problem and
then I should just take it to I mean I'm
okay here
after the smooth but Queen each one is a
lot stronger
just take material yeah you got this and
I don't know about f4 that's I don't
know okay take take b6 and now it should
go in for definitely should go in form
yeah this is an idea suggested by the
compas is a totally unclear position and
now I've to before I'm a lot better him
yeah those two squares are now firmly
under blacks control yeah this is it's
not enough
I wanted the file it's more the
smallness more that's winning for blood
okay could have put up a bit more
resistance but two points as too much
okay guys thanks for watching